good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday
congratulations on making it to the
latter half of the week that is no small
feat you should be incredibly proud of
yourselves i know i am i am as well it's
been a great week so far florida toes
still going strong i see that you're
wearing my slippers
and i didn't really realize that that
had happened no these belong to me now
aren't they gorgeous we're both actually
wearing these are the ska kin pr
slippers and those are skims hotel
slippers i wouldn't realize they were
scams no wonder i've been just like
gravitating towards them speaking of
skims jackie got me the nicest gift like
so unnecessary by the way like i wasn't
even expecting a gift and you were like
i got you something and i thought it was
like you know like a
novelty like one of our like dumb gift
exchange not like a thoughtful
expensive
real like present and i was so not
expecting it i got the skikkin
exfoliator i used it last night it like
i had the longest day yesterday you guys
know i only got two hours of sleep then
we just like worked all day the spritz
meet and greet which was amazing by the
time i got home taking my makeup off
from the morning i was just exhausted
and so i took a bath and i really like
cultivated a nice vibe i'm like let me
do my skin
exfoliator and i was gonna cry like this
is luxury it was so
rich like it was first of all product
wise product review
loved it i told you the exfoliator is on
another level
like if you get one product from skikkin
that i think should be it i mean i
haven't used it i use the moisturizer
but you know they're a lot of good
moisturizers yes i don't have like i use
an olay henriksen exfoliator at home
like it's fine i think i use a kiehl's
one it's fine i've never had an
exfoliating experience like that and i
know you are very into exfoliators so i
wanted to get it for you and then i was
like when you're here it'll be the
perfect time it was so nice and i loved
it so thank you you're welcome um yeah
welcome and ben and margo got here late
last night they're enjoying the florida
vibes already ben wanted me to praise
you on your homemaking skills like ben
had a long day too you know he was up
early working in atlanta got back to
your house at midnight yeah and got into
the bed he was like this is just he took
a shower there's been a lot of talk
about this shower in your guest room
i've been taking baths every night so i
haven't experienced it but everyone in
town is talking about it yep and
ben was like that shower i'm like i know
i got to experience it i gotta get in
there yeah um when you have to wash your
hair do it yeah and then he slept like
so nice and he was just like premium he
wanted me to say premium job welton that
means so much thank you so much i'm so
glad you guys are having a nice time i'm
so glad everyone's here now it's a full
house bryce and magnolia are reunited
nature is healing the love has not been
lost whatsoever they picked up right
where they left off and we can all just
enjoy
do you think it's gross
to drink from a can
that you opened yesterday morning
why would it be gross i don't know
because like it's been open for 24 hours
like with just chilling like um i don't
think it's gross it's just whatever's in
there is probably not very good well i
opened a pellegrino can yesterday and i
guess i didn't finish it and i was just
feeling really thirsty and so i drank it
it was delicious by the way and thanks
to the air conditioning in the studio it
was like it was in the fridge it's cold
um i was just wondering if that's gross
like the only reason why i
with a can it's different because it's a
smaller hole but like with a large cup
like you could get over the course of a
day
but it's small oh a bug
a bug i didn't think about a bug and
there's so many bugs down here uh you're
telling me critters crawling creepy
critters lizards shake it for the burger
chicken for the bees and the frogs at
night the frogs gather on my patio and
they stand there in a line waiting for
the streisbrothers they say come out
come out wherever you are we would love
to kill you no there's literally like
enemies in your own front yard no the
strikes brothers are under attack
it's disgusting and now they have a lady
to protect so they really need to get
their [ __ ] together yeah but there was
just like three
also questions sound off in the comments
are all frogs deadly for dogs or just a
certain kind of toad also what's the
difference between a frog and the toad
that i think is one of the better
questions we've asked here because i've
literally no [ __ ] idea and if you
ever are a dog owner who happens to live
in florida where there's like this frog
there's this killer
community yeah what are your tips and
tricks like you're obviously doing the
thing with your yard but that takes a
couple weeks what are good tips to like
keep dogs safe in florida i didn't
realize there was like this it's
literally like a pandemic for the dogs
yeah no there's constant threats
constant threats it's time these boys
had a little excitement honestly yeah
like new york was too easy for them
they're escaping death every day no and
then when they lay their head on their
pillow at night it's like they deserve
it like they worked hard they evaded
death yeah
oh oh theo's scratching at the door
someone at the door but figure it out
i'm not getting it it's like do you know
how andy has the doorbell like a special
guest we have like scratches at your
door
and it's theo
um
so we did our spritz meet and greet last
night in fort lauderdale we met so many
toasters i think it was our most
populated
most attended yeah event it was so nice
to meet everyone like who lives here so
many people who live here like literally
just moved here so yes a lot of people
who could relate to your experience yes
it was a great group of toasters it was
so fun to meet everyone and it was so
fun to do the meet and greet together i
know we've never done well we've done
one five years ago and we haven't done a
spritz one together um
and when i got home i was like so tired
from talking like my jaw hurt yeah and
it was just so fun so thank you to
everyone who came out and supported
spritz we really appreciate that
and we just appreciate life and these
flamingos obviously
of course i'm going to miss them when
you go and then i go back to my leave
side of things i'll be back you will be
do when do you think you'll be back i
don't know um definitely your birthday
which is i'm not saying nothing before
that but at least we have one trip on
the books for sure your 30th birthday is
in november
um
i feel like i'll probably come down like
for a bunch of episodes like when i'm on
tour like nearby like i have to go to
nashville right i have to go to
nashville yep so i feel like it actually
would probably be beneficial for me to
like spend time here in between some of
those shows that's so true so i can
chill do premium podcasts relax recharge
for shows and then have shorter flights
that's so true right
yeah
okay sounds good i'm also starting to
theorize about when i'm gonna come up to
new york for a visit that'd be crazy
yeah no and like the way i tore apart
our studio i don't know how we're gonna
go back to like our regular episodes
like i
literally you won't recognize it like
it's so different and i moved all the
equipment like and i unplugged a lot of
things
so um we're just gonna need some help
getting that back together okay or you
could we could stay here um i love
podcasting here can i just say like
enjoy it immensely let's talk about
yesterday's episode how it's becoming
like a critically acclaimed episode we
were so funny yeah we covered so many
different topics and the stories were
were great and people are just like
they're adding it to their google doc
their list of episodes
to send to other people like that
they've been trying to get you know a
friend or a family member into the toast
and there's like certain episodes
that'll do it and i do believe yesterday
was one of them
i love that i mean you were really the
star of yesterday's episode
with your recap of the turpin sisters
right no and now um that i've become
like a public turpin like person um i've
been getting so much information so
there was a lawsuit filed three weeks
ago against two against the state or
like the foster care system um because
docs revealed that six of the foster
kids who were taken from the turpin
house into foster homes were victims of
abuse again emotional physical
abuse
so the story is unfolding and i do
believe other um
adult children have started to identify
themselves on social media
okay so it's just it's unraveling slowly
we just keep talking about it yeah yeah
um
but we've got a great show it's thursday
which means i didn't watch real
housewives of beverly hills last night
even though i am all caught up but
that's because i was busy meeting and
greeting so i feel like that's a good
excuse we were so busy we were meeting
and then we were greeting
we were doing both but we sometimes we
greeted and then we made it yeah
oh thank you
um so i feel like let's dive in let's
dive in to the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
scout design studio by the way i have
been getting messages like please tell
me jack is a code for scout we do so
scout is a furniture store based in
dallas where i have gotten so much of
the furniture for my new house including
these two chairs that we're sitting on
right now did i do we order one for my
studio we ordered one from your studio
and then i ordered another one for my
solo endeavors here these chairs are
just taking over the world they're
called the lana ivory
clay chairs i say buckle but i think
it's boucle the thing about boucle is
that it's really it's interpretive
boucle is more personal than comedy
i have a bunch of other pieces from
scout in my house already the lamps in
your room is the bench for my room from
bench in your room it's another boucle
bench it's from scout and i also have
more stuff coming they also have a
sickening art collection all different
kinds of art i have some
wonderful pieces coming also what's so
funny before i started working with
scout house
everyone was tagging me in this piece of
art from scout it says [ __ ] around and
find out in hombre um and it's like
patterned and it's so cool and i'm
actually getting one i will put it in
the studio because it's so ah that's
iconic it's iconic people were tagging
me in that too like send this to jackie
send this to jackie and then i'm like
you were telling me about scout i'm like
i think that's the place let's [ __ ]
around and find out please right right
so they have gorgeous furniture they
have an incredible collection of art
check them out at
scoutdesignstudio.com use code toast for
15 off of your first order and they ship
they ship everywhere everywhere so
maybe i'll like start checking oh
actually you could do your apartment
refresh wait you know that i'm like
refreshing my apartment and i'm working
with the designer and she sent me all
these different options like half of
this stuff was from scout oh i was like
wait use code and we could be use code
you're like what the discount too
we could be twinning like
in here yeah keeping the same energy and
that's what we do with everything like
no we all have the same couch no that's
because like olivia's getting that bench
from scout one thing about me is like
if i see something i like like i am
going to copy the other person of course
which is an annoying trait except
i don't pretend like i came up with it
on my own like i'm acknowledging the
copying and i feel like that makes it
okay except for the spanx pants
okay i feel like i acknowledged that uh
you were the one who told me i got to
get them but then i made it like my
personality trait yeah same with reading
yeah yeah you know what i just got a
partnership with spanx because i sold so
many pants so thanks checks yeah but you
know what that song i can take ownership
and the fact that i never posted the
link
you know you did i can own that and
maybe i should have and maybe it would
have been my partnership 100 but you
know what rising tides rise all shides
so it's like a partnership for one is a
partnership for all like i feel like a
partnership for you is is literally
around the corner
yeah seeing the power of the toast you
know who wouldn't want to work with us
i'm happy for you no i would be annoyed
for sure so
no but like i would i'm acknowledging
like i would be [ __ ] annoying i'm
like [ __ ] i literally gave you that
idea and like you're running to the bank
i'd be [ __ ] annoyed
i'm happy for you you know what i feel
like you deserve a commission on it
honestly
i'll i'll tell i'll tell the business
manager okay maybe one percentage i
think we all kind of
no i just think i think we should all
have a partnership with spanx and i feel
like maybe after they see this episode
things will change yeah just know like i
actually got a targeted facebook ad
that's how i found those white pants
yes i got them i love them i thought
they were so sleek and sophisticated and
i know that you're like on this
sophisticated journey and i was like
claudia these pants would be amazing on
you no and first of all that was so
thoughtful of you those pants have
changed my summer
and i just need those pants
in another color like why do they only
offer them in white and they have a
similar version in like a silver yeah
and that's just not what i'm looking for
what about like a nude that would be
nice every light pink maybe a black
everything yeah it's like the perfect
pant come in another color please not
all of us want to wear white come in
every color summer's almost over right
right right
um so scout thank you so much for that
15 off thank you scout code toast
t-o-a-s-t
how's life with the new ipad this is
week one dave like four i'm gonna be
honest because the ipad is great like no
shade to it but i was really excited
about this keyboard because then i could
type things easier but it's not easy to
type with the streis brothers on my lap
every day not only that um i was using
your ipad and the dimensions of the
keyboard are different than the
dimensions of a classic laptop and the
way i was typing not english because my
fingers you're used to like the same
exact keyboard even if it's like a dell
computer it's the same spacing between
letters generally it's the same size but
this is like a scaled-down version of it
and i was literally typing gibberish
okay that doesn't bother me but the fact
that i can't like fold the keyboard
behind the ipad and then read like this
and then i want to take the ipad off but
then i lose the keyboard and it's like
why'd i get a new ipad no totally
you should i but i was using your ipad
to put in the data for the episode and i
was trying to flip the thing that should
go backwards it should go backwards it
doesn't
design flaw design flaw
okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna do my best
here okay you know what i'm just
taking off hopefully we don't have to
google anything tonight no because we're
literally encyclopedias of knowledge
encyclopedias
our first story jonah hill
former love of ruthie will no longer
promote his films to avoid anxiety
attacks he says and it's an important
step to protect myself in an open letter
penned to fans the wolf of wall street
actor revealed that he will not promote
his upcoming documentary stutz which he
directed when it hits the film festival
circuit later this year
he also wrote that he will skip press
tours and public events for upcoming
projects citing his years-long battle
with anxiety and panic attacks as part
of his decision quote i finished
directing my second film a documentary
about me and my therapist which explores
mental health in general called stutts
the whole purpose of making this film is
to give therapy and the tools i've
learned in therapy to a wide audience
for private use through an entertaining
film his letter began per rolling stone
quote through this journey of
self-discovery within the film i have
come to the understanding that i've
spent nearly 20 years experiencing
anxiety attacks which are exacerbated by
media appearances and public facing
events
he went on to write that he is so
grateful that the film will premiere at
a prestigious film festival this fall
noting that he is excited to share the
project with the world in the hope that
it will help those who are struggling
however you won't see me out there
promoting this film or any upcoming
films while i take this important step
to protect myself if i made myself
sicker by going out there and promoting
it i wouldn't be acting true to myself
or to the film no that's so true
especially because it's a mental health
film
um and this is so
great for him i know this is like
you get to a certain level where you're
allowed to do this i think a lot of
people would love to not do it i think a
lot of people struggle those events are
like really chaotic i think a lot of
people have been open about that but you
have to get to a certain level where
like you're employable even if you don't
do media because media is half the job
you go and act in something and then the
months afterwards are the other half
promotion so um it's the way that like
the industry works that like not
everyone is going to be able to book
roles if they don't agree to media so
this is obviously like a privilege and
you know what like good for him because
you got to do you got to protect your
space yeah i do feel like he's one of
these actors who's really in it for the
art yeah and
wants to like act and loves the craft
and also loves directing and is not
interested in the fame side of things
and i feel like if he even had to choose
between some roles if you know if he is
not doing media and that doesn't work he
would be okay turning that down because
he's only interested at this point in
the acting right he has like artistic
integrity
also i'm sure this is unintentional but
this is actually really good press for
the movie of course because he's
prioritizing his mental health the
movie's about mental health also it is a
big announcement and it's promoting yes
but no but it's also just like the life
imitating art piece where it's like i've
come to this decision and you can watch
the movie to find out how and why it's
literally life imitating art yeah and
now it just feels like there is this
opportunity like they're like he will
not be attending events and that there's
room for one more so i am available and
um if anybody needs me on a red carpet
in lieu of
jonah i'm a great time
i love to look glamorous
um i'll make you some click baity type
of headlines i can be bought is what i'm
saying
i think that would be really cool i
would like to nominate ruthie to go to
those events instead of jonah or with
him and maybe he'd feel you know more at
ease more comfortable with like a safe
space by his side like a rock on his arm
right it'll really it'll actually like
stabilize him great thank you that was
the word i was looking for it would
ground him i do think
that he could also use a ruthie in his
life and that you know that would also
cause a lot of positive change but i'm
not going to go down this road that's
the lesson here is that like find your
ruthie
find your ruthie and don't let her go no
because jonah made that mistake once and
he continues to pay for it honestly
continues
like every relationship that he's so
stoked about
pales in comparison terrific what he
could have had with ruthie 100
um not to be annoying but your mic flag
is upside down again well here's why
because i've been constantly changing
the position of my microphone when i'm
reading it's down here when we go to do
what like a deer toasters
i go this way so i'm between flags in
between flags and you know what
i like this about myself okay
and soon you're going to be between
flights too and be like being between
and then i'm going to get a sponsorship
with
between two flags you know i've got a
sponsorship with six flags because i'm
talking about it because you have so
many flags and different positions and
you'll be like [ __ ] i'll be i'll
literally get a sponsorship with the
company that made this i think it's
called like pbs or something it'd be
like being between two flags is the best
thing ever yeah no i can't believe there
was a time in my life when i wasn't
between two flags hashtag and i'll just
be sitting here
no that would literally be like if i got
a sponsorship with like kendall
oh my gosh because like you not only did
you like try so hard to get me to read
for so many years and i was like so
stubborn then i started reading and you
were like kendall kendall i'm like now
now i'm like
yeah yeah and now like kindle's my
personality yeah no and the kindle that
you had up until last week was yours
yeah oh my god that's so [ __ ] up yeah
oh that i think
things you can have
really most things i'm i love to share
no you're very good with that but yeah
no i think that would that would cut
deep yeah also yesterday at the meet and
greet people brought their kindles for
us to sign and i actually don't think
i've ever been so honored
and flattered yeah that was cool because
it's so permanent it's so permanent and
it's like
we're fixtures in the reading community
which i you know i i had a feeling you
know redheads does of course
but
that's pretty cool no it's extremely
cool how like when people think of
reading they think of you like that's
cool that's so cool it's pretty cool
it's never too late to become a redhead
our next book is a snitch's choice which
is when most people do become redheads
because it's a pretty easy barrier to
enter right
except snitch is doing a little
something different we're reading a book
called everything i know about love by
dolly alderton it just became a series
on peacock where it's coming out like
next week so it's perfect timing i've
been seeing this book everywhere like
outside of the redhead so it's like a
good relevant choice yeah and i think
it's more snitch is always like rom-com
erotica i think it's still like cute and
fun like that but a little more in this
not self-help but like
introspective
memoir territory i actually do think
it's a memoir i love the name of dolly
yeah what name do you like name your
child
that you like nickname them dolly dahlia
yeah or you just go full dolly yeah
but i like i like a nickname
i like a nickname too
what's dolly parton's full name
definitely dolly or it's like not even
that right it's like sarah yeah right
that's like kiki palmer's name is lauren
oh i didn't know that and her middle
name is lauren like
it starts with a k so she think everyone
thinks that her name is kiki because her
middle name is k but no actually it was
just like a family nickname
it's giving snitch energy like 100 yeah
i have like
like i've always loved kiki palmer but
like my new favorite thing to do is like
when i'm getting ready to be watching
random interviews she does because it's
just like gorgeous little tidbits of her
being so [ __ ] funny um and i just
recommend spending like wasting your
days away doing that i watched her hot
ones interview her hot ones it's like
one of the most critically clear
so good because now everyone does hot
ones it's like a stop on the press tour
but she was like one of the first
not first but like but back when it
wasn't like a popular thing to do she
did it and like the hot ones community
regards her episode is like one of the
top ones she was so funny oh i would
love to watch it she went all the way up
to like that what do they do 10 wings
and like she literally might as well
have been eating a salad like she didn't
feel a thing that's crazy where it's
like i always think if i ever did that
like the first one is usually like the
store bought like sriracha i'd be dead
on the floor i cannot eat spicy [ __ ] no
like you actually couldn't be famous
because you can't do that you can't do
uh like eat the one with james corden oh
my god eat it spill it steal your guts
no i just literally be telling everyone
everything spill your kids for filling
your cups sometimes i'm like up at night
and i'm like really worried like i would
literally have to spill my guts yeah no
there's so many things like that
um
are required when you're a celebrity
that actually are torture like even
those days like for photo shoots where
you're literally up at six doing glam
checking out you're you're literally
working for 12 hours before you even get
to in front of the camera so that [ __ ]
looks horrible yeah it's so hot oh my
god like no and people are like putting
you in makeup and clothes like you have
no approval on like you're just the muse
[ __ ] that
no
if it ain't loose fitting i don't want
it if it ain't the sphinx white pants
right and if like the glam isn't
literally like a black line and a nude
lipstick please stay the [ __ ] away from
me
are you ready for our next story yeah
kanye is in some hot water for selling
easy gap clothes in large garbage bags
and he says he's not
here to sit up and apologize about my
ideas so kanye's been facing backlash
for selling his new yeezygap clothing
line in what appeared to be trash bags
uh they show pictures of these large not
trash bags but
like black black plastic bags saying
this is how they're selling easy gap the
sales associate said kanye got mad when
he saw they had it on hangers and this
is how he wanted it they won't help you
find your size too you just have to dig
through everything so
kanye said quote i'm an innovator and
i'm not here to sit up and apologize
about my ideas that's exactly what the
media tries to do make us apologize for
any idea that doesn't fall under exactly
the way they want us to think
so obviously like as a shopper if i
walked into a store like i wouldn't you
know enjoy this experience of rummaging
through a bag for my size um but it's
not like kanye doesn't have like this
was an intentional choice it's like i
think he's thinking of it as some sort
of like art display and i don't
understand art but i believe that's what
he's doing and while it wouldn't be a
pleasant shopping experience for me he's
like he's made it clear in more ways
than one that like he is an artist he
doesn't do things conventional ways and
this is the way he's doing it and there
are his fans fans of him and fans of
yeezy like will be excited by this it's
like a different way personally like it
wouldn't be fun for me but like i
respect the artistic choice you know
yeah he said the clothing display
intends to make life easier and informal
so that we can all basically dress in
the dark right it's like a statement on
something it's art like it's a statement
on something but like practically
you know that's not how i want to shop
like when i can shop online i can just
like go to a rack that i like and then
go to my side like refine price low to
high size xl right but this is a
shopping experience
whilst making a statement and
participating in art installation and if
that is for you
enjoy and if it's not just go to
shopmorningtoast.com and you can just
shop by your size in the item that you
want that's really really good advice
also like i don't understand like the
backlash to this like don't go
right backlash like i have such a
problem with backlash culture like
you want to make a statement on why this
is problematic so literally don't buy it
like no one's forcing you right and it's
not like this is you need this to live
no and there it's not like you went to
the stores and it was chaos and there's
clothes everywhere in garbage bags
because they didn't get it on the
hangers it's messy you don't like his
intentional yeah then i mean i
personally don't get it and that's not
how i want to shop um
but a lot of times connie is like ahead
of you know the
joggers like so
i will wait and see on this
but i really just don't see how it's
practical i don't think it's gonna
become like a trend i just think like
it's an artistic choice
and
people with the backlash like if okay if
he was putting oxygen that people need
to breathe and selling it like this that
would be problematic you don't like the
experience like don't go you don't have
to write a whole [ __ ] tweet about it
okay like about why it's problematic we
really don't care
yeah
yeah
okay cool
oh sorry no continue are you ready for
our next story only if it's a story
that's brought to you by spirit society
it is it is soak up summer with sprit
society these sparkling cocktails aren't
like most they're made with real
california white wine and natural fruit
flavors they're perfect for any occasion
from pregame to poolside and speaking of
flavors there's one for everyone from
the four originals grapefruit blood
orange pineapple and lemon to our flavor
of the summer peach and if you can't
decide on which one you want to try
first or you just love them all try the
ultimate spritz taste test with the
variety eight pack and you can add peach
to your cart to get the complete set so
sports society as you guys know is a
company that we founded that we're
really proud of it is a gorgeous
gorgeous canned beverage you can get it
at spritsociety.com we are sold in a
couple states right now we're in florida
we're in chicago we're in
texas texas we're in boston georgia
california
um at bevmo we're in total wine so if
you just go to the spritsociety.com
website you can purchase directly from
there and get it shipped to your house
or you can use the store locator to find
a store near you i know we're on
nantucket snitch was in untucked you saw
it in the liquor store um i know we're
in some stores in the hamptons so we're
in a bunch of different stores obviously
we're growing as fast as we can in terms
of getting the product into stores and a
lot of the stores have peach already but
some of them don't if you want to
guarantee you can get peach which people
are quaking i think peach was like the
number one sold last night at the meet
and greet it's so good um you can get it
onlinespritsociety.com and you can use
code toast to get 10 off of the
grapefruit blood orange pineapple lemon
and peach flavors all of our flavors you
can get 10 off at spritsociety.com using
code toast chars
chars y'all
chars to the buccanars
our next story uh love is blind season
two couple ayanna and jarrett are
getting divorced ayanna mcneely and
jarrett jones who said i do during
season two of love is blind are going
their separate ways the netflix stars
announced they are divorcing after
nearly a year of marriage in a joint
statement shared to instagram on
wednesday quote after much thought we're
saddened to share that we have separated
and will begin the process of divorcing
they told fans they still have love for
each other noting that their lives are
simply going in different directions and
coming to this decision was far from
easy and we'll always wish each other
the best yada yada
like if you watch obviously this isn't
the most surprising thing because like
he had proposed to someone else
literally a minute before um but they
did end up getting married and they did
end up i think being married for
at least a year because almost a year
so
at that point i'm like oh maybe it was
like editing and maybe they're just like
legit so
i do find it surprising
is this our first divorce by the way
from love is blind yes because the first
two couples are still married the
hamiltons and amber and barnett who both
turned out to be like actual like
perfect matches for each other it's
crazy is anyone else married from this
season yes the
yes nick and danielle yes okay so at
least they're still together and by the
way i have faith that they that they are
meant for each other like they just
radiate the same energy yeah
except like where the dancing on the
tables and her hat in her apartment
yeah yeah and like her like getting the
notovirus in mexico and then yelling at
him like to get out which was relatable
yeah but that's like real relationships
like how things go and all of a sudden
you're in a fight and you were like mad
about something you took it out on and
now you're just like in a weird fight
and you're watching him from the balcony
talking to other people that literally
happened last night like with me in bed
i was just so tired and i was like being
rude because i got two hours of sleep
and he got home late and he was like
being chatty and i'm like please like
kind of please go to bed and he was like
we haven't seen each other like in a
week like can we talk and i was like
good night that's funny you should have
fallen asleep before he got there that
way he wouldn't like disturb you yeah
but like i wanted to see him i love him
yeah you should want to chat you know
pretended to be asleep that's i ben has
never not come home past 11 o'clock
where i've been awake and not pretending
to be asleep i'm always like if you
acknowledge that you're up like then you
are actually going to be up and they're
gonna think like it's okay no no no like
i'm up and like i'm up but i'm not up no
no no i'm sorry
i'll fake for a minute and then like
jump out and scare him like i still want
to see him i'm just like i want him to
think i was asleep always yeah no i'm
just like if i fake i'm gonna sleep i'm
gonna fall asleep in five minutes right
if he knows that i'm awake i'll fall
i'll be able to go to sleep in an hour
yeah yeah yeah but ben ben had like i
think sleeps so many times like he knows
if my phone is even remotely close to me
he that means like i heard the door open
i just like put my phone down and
started sleeping but if my phone is like
on the nightstand then he knows i'm
really asleep got it but now i know that
he knows that so i put the phone on the
nightstand that's really funny it's it's
one of my most annoying qualities as a
wife for sure that you fake sleeping and
then scare him yeah i fake sleep and
like usually he's like oh you're faking
you're faking and then i'm like yeah but
sometimes i think this was a thing
between me too sometimes i'll take it
really far he's like i know you're
faking i know you're thinking then i'll
like tickle me and i'll i'll i'll stay
good he's like oh [ __ ] she's asleep then
he like goes to get dressed whatever get
in the shower i'm like ah i can't it's
so mean that is so mean especially
because if ben ever did that to me
because i scare very easily i would be
so mad like genuinely upset he knows not
to do it because i i get so scared
especially at night no
that's really crazy i wouldn't that's
really crazy that you do that
i just feel like waking someone when
they're sleeping is one of the weirdest
things that you could do so inhumane
yeah and also sometimes if like zack's
coming in i might be like in like
drifting off and like yes technically i
heard that you came in but i'm not gonna
come out of my slumber for it that is
extremely reasonable that's what i'm
saying no of course if you're like
halfway there yeah you shouldn't stop no
don't turn back don't turn back even
though like for me if i heard something
while i was halfway there i'm awake in
those first couple of minutes like
leading into sleep i'm extremely
sensitive then a bomb could go off and
i'm asleep i'm not hearing it got it
well you know for ayanna and jarrett
obviously they didn't have these things
worked out it's divorce for them i
really liked jared i like diana too like
i think that
they were nice people but i don't think
they were a perfect match me too the way
like i watched the season and then when
i
read this i was just like who what oh
yeah and then i was like was that five
years ago no two months ago
it's that's the reality tv turnover rate
these days it's like people come in and
out of your brain in 30 seconds yeah
this was faster than anything i've
experienced even though like the
original love is blind season was such a
cultural shift
i think it was when people really
stopped watching the bachelor honestly
like i think it had such an impact on
reality tv that i remember everything
that happened i remember everyone's name
of course it was the best time of my
life yeah no it was it was peak living
because it was also like coveted right
before covid you know things were in
full swing
it was a great time
cheer on netflix yeah but then cheer
season two womp womp it was fine i mean
then the jerry stuff like it was wompy
yeah
it was wampy as hell and by then it
wasn't like it wasn't this random thing
nobody knew about then there was like a
cult following it's always more fun when
there's a documentary on the most random
[ __ ] thing and like it galvanizes the
nation well that leads us to our next
story i've never had a better segue in
our whole career bama rush is officially
being turned into a documentary
so every fall like
clockwork more and more tick-tock users
lose themselves in a very specific niche
bama rush videos there's just something
so captivating about the university of
alabama's hyper meticulous sorority rush
rituals that totally takes over tick
tock for a full week in august but now
fans of the videos can dive into the
craze even deeper because a bama rush
documentary is being made to fully
explore how preppy ootd videos viral
dance battles and over-the-top events
turned one college campus into
tick-tock's favorite playground wait so
is the documentary about like how it
became viral or about bama rush like
dive diving deep the documentary has
been filming throughout this year's
sorority recruitment week which took
place from august 6 to august 14th and
it is about
the varela women no and the just bam of
the week um quote the film the film is a
thoughtful and compassionate portrayal
of young women in 2022 as they rush the
sorority system at the university of
alabama it will be vice studios
producing the documentary in partnership
with hbo max where will almost certainly
premiere isn't extremely exclusive so it
will be about you know exactly what you
see on tick tock and then i imagine plus
the tick tock element like how how they
feel about it right so last year it was
all about michaela what would jimmy
buffet do that was her username and if
you follow her which i still do um she's
been talking about this like and she's i
don't know she has like a weird take on
it because i think like they wanted her
to be a part of it and then it didn't
work out so her nda was void and then
she like started going off on tick tock
so is she like a sophomore now so she's
a sophomore and when she was a freshman
like she was
last year was the first year that it
happened so she was like the star but
there was like a few people who everyone
was following but her story got crazy
because everyone was loving her she was
like so cute and she like okay here's my
outfit and her pants were always from
the pant store and everyone's like what
the [ __ ] is the pants store
um
but then she got dropped
and it was crazy and then that's really
what like turned this into like more of
a real thing because everyone was like
quietly following and then we were like
wait michaela got dropped we're delta
we're dealt again
um so
everyone's like why didn't mckay like i
dropped there were so many rumors and
she had so many followers and she was
going live and there was like a video of
her that had went viral when she was in
high school i think maybe was even on
barstool like and she was just drunk and
like there's really strict rules in
alabama like when it comes to sororities
when it comes to drinking vaping um your
grades so she got dropped and then like
everyone moved on after that because it
was over no like there can't be internet
proof of you being like a delinquent
even though that's literally what
college is about um and that's what you
do
in a sorority right but like
front-facing they're like these
philanthropic organizations so you have
to have like a really clean social media
presence and that video of her and i
think it had a lot to do with like the
fact that she got really popular and
that video resurfaced for that reason on
tick tock um so she got dropped and then
this year it happened again and it's
just so interesting like all the girls
who it's funny like on the first she's
not in a sorority she's a sophomore not
necessarily but just an influencer yes
on campus this is also really good like
right also nice just as good honestly
but then this year when it first started
it's funny like it's like now everyone
knows so there were like a ton of really
cute girly southern girlies getting on
doing their outfits it's sisterhood day
it's paneletic day or whatever um
and then it's funny like how it weeds
out and then like a few the algorithm
chooses like a few people to keep moving
forward but like day one you saw like 10
girls day two you saw like five and now
the star is i think her name is kalyn
i've heard of her i hope you're having a
great day not just a good day she had
the slogan which is a great marketing
technique for anyone you know listening
who might be going to university of
alabama next year get yourself a slogan
and on her first video that went viral
she was wearing the cutest pair of gucci
shorts
and and she was wearing like lululemon
and all the comments were like oh my god
there's a rich one so everyone just
became obsessed with her because she was
like very um
uh what's the word uh aspirational thank
you so much oh my god i couldn't find
the word she was very aspirational and
then she ended up being like really cute
and really sweet and she had this little
slogan this little phrase was a perfect
recipe for virality
and i'm sure she will be a star of the
documentary um she ended up getting zeta
and you know they all go to the stadium
if you make it through the whole week
without getting like dropped you go to
the stadium you get an envelope and you
like listen to this whole like panel and
then they count down from ten like you
cannot open open the envelope until so
she was videoing ten nine eight and she
opens it and like she looked like kind
of pissed and she's like this really
sweet soft-spoken girl and she was just
like quiet she like opened the video she
was like i'm zeta and then ended the
video is that not the one she wanted but
it's the one she got she never told us
what she wanted
i don't think you're allowed to honestly
like i wonder if like i'm sure you know
for all of us watching on tick tock it's
like how could you not take kaden right
i love her right you know she's the best
in the class but like when you're in it
on campus i wonder if being that person
is actually not
helpful at all i don't know but they
also say like what i've been i've been
diving deep into sorority culture what
they say is like you have to trust the
system like even if you get a
sorority that like it was unexpected or
not like the number one choice for you
like it was meant for you like you have
to trust the system and then like a year
later the girls are like oh man i'm so
glad i trusted the system of course like
because you bloom where you're planted
and what you're gonna go to a sorority
and like hate it the whole time i love
that isn't that a nice sign
i'm gonna cry i love that i just write
that down
you bloom that was the perfect phrase
which just pick that out of your back
pocket that was exactly what i was
trying to say i heard it once like uh
seven years ago like in a meeting when i
was uh
working corporate corporate and it just
really
resonated with me you bloom where you're
planted i love that and that's exactly
like trust the system no you just have
to live there so you end up having fun
because right what are you gonna do it's
the same thing just a different name
it's there's still like girls and also
it's the same thing right right and
everyone is nice and sweet for the most
part that you know there's there's the
same dynamics everywhere it's just a
different name yeah as kiki popper says
she once wanted to be in a sorority but
they're very political they really are
girls can be so [ __ ] mean they really
are and then like this is like pink
sorority greek life and because this is
like sydney white right there's it's
like the southern but now there's the
element of like potential fame so like
the stakes are even higher but i kind of
like that
you would think okay we're now that bama
rush is like this viral thing the girl
who becomes like the most famous from it
is going to get prepped in every single
house but i kind of like how like they
don't really care about what's happening
like i'm sure they like that they're
going viral and that people are into
what they're doing and they're not
letting it impact influencing like
actually who's going into the right
house yeah i am curious and hopefully
the documentary will cover this like
what does the university itself have to
have to say has this impacted admissions
or like the number of applicants they
get i assume after last year peop
because you watch it and it looks fun
and it's good marketing for the school
looks like i want to be a part of this
and if i was thinking of maybe applying
to like university of alabama or auburn
maybe i'll go university of alabama
so i'm curious if it's had like a
positive impact on the school as a
business you know i'm sure that it
mostly has
i'm also sure like everything else there
will be a swing
yeah no and eventually it'll just become
like annoying and like just friends will
get involved i mean kendra scott is like
when alabama rush sharks it's like where
do we sign up like they were commenting
on everyone already sending out packages
to the girls who they started like i
don't think anyone who works for the
kendra scott marketing team specifically
the tick tock team has slept in a week
okay well take a beat
because kendra scott like
is sorority and university of alabama
specifically yeah and like lululemon too
but really kendra scott
crazy well that sounds really good and
also it's perfect for me because i'm not
keeping up with it on tug talk obviously
but i am interested by it in the
documentary i just want to be explained
it i want to see the ins and outs i want
to meet everyone um and i feel like it's
this thing where like a lot of people
are talking about it but also a lot of
people are like what's going on at the
university of alabama there's like they
know that it's trending but they're not
sure what for and they definitely don't
know how it started so a documentary
would be extremely helpful in this case
i hope they can turn it around kind of
quickly because they obviously used last
week as the burrito filmed right so like
get it to us soon soon please thank you
very much
our fifth and final story
these are the nerdiest states in america
our fifth and final some data human
interests thought provoking story we're
talking about the nerdiest states okay i
want to guess but let's talk about what
does it mean to be a nerd so
that's a different question i'm gonna
tell you how they judged it okay they
surveyed more than 1 000 people to ask
them about their home decorating habits
and analyze more than 3 100 google
search terms and phrases
relating to nerdy house decorations
including terms like hobbit wreath iron
man gaming chair to crown the nerdy
estates in america so that's actually an
interesting way of
like gathering data and also defining a
nerd like people who are really into
books tv shows movies and games being
into tv doesn't make you a nerd no but
like when it's game of thrones right
like you go to like comic-con it's like
we're so nerdy no we are i mean we're
into like electronics we read we're
really smart
are we nerds by the way we're like
kendall like
you know like we're really not like
other girls like we're kind of like
nerdy yeah i just like kind of love to
read and i don't want to you know go to
parties i just want to be home with my
kindle and look if i am going to go to a
party like i'll probably just drink a
beer because like that's what i like to
drink and i love game of thrones like
not you know i was watching it before
everyone was watching it and a lot of
people were upset with the ending but
like personally like we understood it
you know we read the books where george
was coming from right and his artistic
vision and why kanye wants people to
shop out of trash bags right okay so
given that i think
there's no rhyme or reason to this
honestly and is the percentage has to be
based on population right just because
there's more nerds in california but
it's a bigger you know we've got more
nerds in california than oregon
i was going to say oregon for the top
one no
oregon's number 10 though so that's
pretty good okay
because like people in like portland and
like that area like they're like kind of
like hipster or like yeah like seattle
yeah yeah that's washington but like
that general area yes that's pacific
northwest it's very like granola
portland is very yeah it's like the
hipster capital of america yeah i don't
know if everyone knows that yeah
it didn't say the most hipster state i
know but i associate like a similar
voice like hipsters don't watch lord of
the rings and that's like you know
hipsters read sure and they like do
certain things they wear glasses
crossovers they're glasses like nerds
there's a venn diagram in the middle
there's there's a definitely across the
middle is glasses but on one side
is you know like artisanal coffee beans
right and the other side is the hobbit
right right going to comic con
yeah okay number one nebraska
oh shocking number two new mexico
also shocking number three nevada
shocking because it's las vegas yeah but
like that's literally like two miles of
all of the state you know i guess number
four utah
also shocking number five kansas
okay
six arkansas
you know arkansas spell like our
campaign
yeah
i wonder why
well um
actually it's spelled sorry that's wrong
it's called arkenstein
can i read it
um these states like
are
like all the same the same do you know
what i mean yeah maybe that's just
because i'm not familiar like with what
the personality type of a typical
arkenstein is no but these aren't
coastal states right they're all kind of
similar
regionally in a sense so i guess like
it's landlocked regionally it's nerdy
region new york california is not on
there no jersey no anything in the
tri-state area no
that's interesting yeah
oh connecticut is number nine
that's weird this study makes no [ __ ]
sense yeah no it was only like a
thousand people surveyed and i just
don't think that's a big enough sample i
agree and that's i think the problem the
biggest problem with family feud they're
asking a hundred people
it's not enough
yeah
but i just want everyone to know
quantity shows the story i did i did
well we have been like in like the last
couple years added to the weirdest
[ __ ] like bistros sisters for like
press releases when it comes to like we
have you know interviews with gurus
random studies that and we were looking
for stories and i just like checked my
email i'm like oh we got one should we
use it and yeah i love uh you know
state-by-state analysis i love pitting
states against one another in every
different way i love lists you know like
most popular halloween costume by state
yeah most popular like porn you like
data
i love the data i
i know lie i really do you know you are
you're a nerd
you love crunching numbers
i love when the numbers are crunched for
me of course and i'm presented with what
the data means it's like a snackable and
we can extrapolate from the data
relevant information yeah but i don't
feel like i was able to extrapolate
anything from that moronic study because
it was shitty data it was a shitty like
yeah it was a good concept
but i don't feel like the no and
lombardo homes no offense you should
have spent your efforts looking at the
most popular podcast by state we're
still waiting that's what we should have
done
we're still waiting
we're waiting cautiously though yeah no
because like
we're escaping only release it if we're
on it at least once you know
yeah if it's not just like that in the
trash say like you know oh this stuff
has been compromised this data has been
compromised
those were the fast-paced fairies you
definitely needed to know every single
one of them and i'm so glad we did one
um that is our show our second to last
episode of the week
we're back tomorrow anything else we
need to like plug girl with no job.com
tour
no redheads is you know always there for
you whenever you want to join us always
patreon we have new episodes we're doing
more this week because we're still
together and patreon is just a lovely
community and then you get access to
toast after dark and that's like where
all the fun happens truly
uh and the stress brothers love you and
so just remember that every streis
brother loves you
it didn't sound like the sentence was
over love i just wanted you to that let
that sink in i mean yeah you left us
waiting for me i wanted that moment of
silence you could you yes you i'm
talking to you and your car you at your
desk you are going for a hot girl
walking you pumping stress brothers love
you
and so do we so do we thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we we
deliver oh sorry i forgot to update
everyone we were approved for our
plaques they are in route
we had to pay an extra 150 just to get
two because like we just we both deserve
happily for each of our studios i was
like
where do i sign a really great art wall
happening between my plaque my [ __ ]
around and find out mm-hmm
some framed photo about photos of us yes
photos of the stripes brothers yeah yeah
yeah some fan artwork that would be cool
yeah i'll start building up a little
collection sorry i forgot to update
everyone like i was
waiting for the approval and then it all
just happened so fast yeah they reached
out i was like oh my gosh
us no couldn't be us
so thank you guys because we couldn't do
that without you so oh and i just want
to update everyone because i actually am
like trying to get tick tock on my ipad
oh yeah but my charger's not charging on
my ipad because it got used to your ipad
instead of mine no it was connected to
your college email which recently
deactivated yes so uh i can't get into
my tic tac account i'm not making a new
one because mine is literal perfection
agreed we have reached out to tick tock
hopefully they get back to us if you
work at tick tock like hit us up please
yeah if you can help me with that oh
wait there was a girl that meet
yesterday who worked at tick tock we
should have asked her i didn't know
until last night
um so i'm trying because i really like
want to see the fan edits and support
the turpin sisters but maybe it's not
meant to be for me no no there's been so
much good like user generated toast
content no i know i was on tick tock
like i was sending you all them i saw so
what
hashtag
operate
mission no
operation get jackie back
operation get jackie back on tick tock
commence
come in
we're a monthly friday on youtube if
you're watching this on youtube to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found that's
spotify itunes stitch or public video i
have radio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcast find us
the morning toast and leave a five star
view about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing and crayoub day and we'll see
you tomorrow goodbye